you're very comfortable in your
masculinity you talk very openly about
the fact that you you love French
manicures is that true yeah when I get
uh spawned and grown dipped and whipped
so did and booty goated and loaded I
like to have my nails done I don't know
what just happened I
[Applause]
so so I I understand one word of that
well basically I think you get your
nails cut right I get my nails cut and
done when I'm out in the town when I'm
doing my thing you know that's why I say
when I'm spooned and groomed dipped in
whipped suited and booted goated and
loaded now I got it yeah now I'm with
you um and so and so uh that you like
that and your that your fingernails look
beautiful by the way they look very
shiny mine are all chewed up and it's
all a little bit you know you got to
have player Tendencies about yourself
you know you got to be groomed you got
to be groomed yeah yeah you got to take
care of it and you also I'm I'm told
you're not you're not afraid to
to walk around with is it a purse that
you have that's a verse
a man's purse yeah yeah yeah what do you
keep in that the goods
[Applause]
well now we know yes sir
nobody
let me talk about your uh your family
for a second your daughter uh Corey she
sings now and she's quite good but when
she started out you were on camera
because you were doing a reality show
there's footage of you being pretty
harsh with her yeah I told her the truth
when she couldn't sing I told her she
was horrible wow okay but she you know
she's made with what I'm made with so
she wouldn't got vocal coaching she went
and got strong and she pursued it and
she became great at what she doing so it
actually worked you were honest with her
and it made her say I'm going to show
you I don't lie to my kids I tell them
the truth so that way they know the real
truth so it's uncut so when they go and
deal with the real world it won't be a
surprise right because I I'm around
parents all the time they're telling
their kids like oh you're the best
basketball player I've ever seen the
kid's terrible you know so I tell them
the truth so that way it won't be a rude
awakening right right that's very good I
won't do that but
I'm just gonna keep lying get them from
childhood what's up with the documentary
uh really terrific job uh you shoot a
lot of this in Jamaica
and how did you uh did Jamaica feel like
a second home to you now I mean it was a
natural call and you know I wanted to
make reggae music in Jamaica's the birth
of Reggae music and I wanted to go there
to really seek out the true origins of
Reggae music and once I got there I
found Rastafari reggae music and the
whole journey was being captured by Vice
pictures so we shot it you know what I'm
saying and put it together and now it's
on documentary so you could see it March
15th coming to a theaters near you
uh and you
the uh yeah it's also the documentary
it's not just about you and reggae it's
also about your journey yeah my journey
in life and what you've gone through in
life and it's interesting because we've
all known you for so long as Snoop Dogg
and and then we find out about your your
past and some of the painful things you
went through growing up yeah because in
this in this documentary uh Slash
Journey I'm able to open up and take you
inside you know places where I've never
been able to talk about to take you from
my days of Death Row Records all the way
to where I'm at right now to be able to
know relationships that I have with
certain people who aren't here anymore
and just to see you know exactly what I
went through to become Snoop Dogg to to
give you great music for 20 years yeah
you talk or in one point in the
documentary about friends would invite
you over to their houses
and this was you're not afraid to open
up you said friends would invite you
over to their house and you would when
you were much younger and you would
steal from them that was my white
friends yeah
so
hey man I was from the hood and you know
and I got the opportunity
I seized the opportunity right
forgive me I'll pay y'all back I can't
say who y'all is but I'll pay y'all back
all right well just so you know as
payback I'm keeping this
that's my
[Applause]